school girls running for their lives
after a rocket lands near their school
part of a coordinated attack on the
capital kabul
[Applause]
more than 20 rockets landed in
residential areas near the green zone
where many embassies are based witnesses
say the attack during the morning rush
hour was timed to cause maximum damage
it was morning and we were leaving our
home when an explosion happened
two of my sisters and my mother were
wounded so we took them to hospital
it was around 9 00 am rockets hit the
bakery wounding an employee who needed
hospital treatment
lots of shopkeepers are going to suffer
financially because of this
isil has claimed responsibility for the
attack
it came as the u.s secretary of state
mike pompeo arrived in cattle's capital
doha
he's scheduled to talk to both afghan
government and taliban negotiators
involved in peace talks there it shows
breaches and security that are just
breathtaking yet again
that this sort of weaponry could get
into the city
and secondly it's part of a trend with
greater violence in the cities mainly
assassinations magnetic bombs
car bombs even at a time when the
taliban have said that they won't be
launching attacks on urban centers
isil has been behind recent attacks on
the capital gunmen stormed kabul
university three weeks ago
at least 22 people were killed
the government says in saturday's attack
fighters fired the rockets from the back
of two trucks
it's investigating how the vehicles
managed to enter the city
and get so near to the heavily fortified
green zone
victoria gatenby al jazeera